the first glimpses we got of frozen -
didn't tell us much but this latest
trailer finally gives us a clearer
picture of the sequel storyline and
we've scoured each and every frame for
possible clues about what to expect in
frozen - at the beginning of frozen we
see the picturesque kingdom of arendelle
which sits at the edge of the sea
nestled into a wall of towering cliffs
set apart from the villages arendelle
Castle rimmed with stone walls and
topped with pointed green roofs however
by the end of the film the castle has
been transformed not by the premature
winter which Elsa brings about after
losing control of her powers but by
gleaming ice crystals that beautifully
adorned all the rooftops and spires
making the castle appear frosty white
the opening shot of the frozen - trailer
establishes that arendelle Castle is
still sporting its new look the white
tipped castle sitting next to a peaceful
town surrounded by lush green grass by
showing us that Elsa is still glazing
the castle and beautiful layers of ice
we can assume that not only is Elsa
still reigning as Queen but that she's
in full control of her powers and at
peace with her people the frozen -
trailer opens with a flashback as king
Agner tells young anna and elsa a story
about an enchanted forest in the story
we see an image of a young golden-haired
boy in arendelle colours arriving in the
forest between what appears to be two
palace guards then we see a young girl
twirling through the air and it's hard
not to see the similarity between her
and the dark-haired Iduna these two
children were also shown in an earlier
trailer where the boy was the one being
tossed and the girl was the one watching
is it possible that this is a glimpse of
the first meeting of ignore any Doudna
and that Iduna is in fact from the
enchanted forest
that could explain where Elsa's magic
came from born with the powers are
cached born and they're getting stronger
both previous frozen - teasers have
shown us a scene in which one of the
sisters was surrounded by hovering icy
diamonds now we have another piece of
the puzzle with the revelation that the
diamonds that Elsa creates seem to match
the symbols on the Stonehenge like
pillars that mark the entrance to the
enchanted forest
the trailer makes it
as though one of the central questions
of frozen - will be where Elsa's powers
came from and her ability to create
symbols she's presumably never seen
before maybe a major clue all signs seem
to point to some sort of significant
link between Elsa and the enchanted
forest
but we'll have to wait to find out
whether it's the source of her power the
homeland of one of her parents or
connected to her magic in some other way
we never had much doubt that Anna Elsa
Kristoff and Olaf would return for
frozen - but less certain were the fates
of all the endearing side characters
from the first film while it would have
been easy enough for Disney to sweep
frozen's minor characters aside to make
room for a new crop we now know at least
a few familiar faces will be making an
appearance in frozen - in a shop that
presumably takes place shortly after the
citizens of arendelle have been forced
to flee the village we see the trolls
bull de cliff and paw be who cared for
Kristoff as a child standing in front of
the displaced townspeople behind them is
oaken the good-natured owner of oaken's
trading post and Sanne who made the most
of his brief appearance in the first
film now back up while I deal with this
crook here
if I did you call me well it seems as
though the trolls may still have a
significant role to play in frozen -
chances are that oaken's appearance will
be more of a cameo still it's nice to
see him again and maybe this time we'll
even get to meet his family mm-hmm
family when Elsa here is a mysterious
voice calling to her she sets out on a
quest to figure out who it is or at
least that's the impression of frozen
twos plot that we get from the trailer
which sees Anna immediately volunteering
to accompany her sister as she ventures
north in search of answers from the
looks of it frozen 2 will be largely
Elsa's movie similar to how frozen was
mostly about Anna Elsa appears to be on
her own for a number of scenes in the
trailer including the one where she
approaches the wall of mist surrounding
the enchanted forest
it's easy to miss since in the very next
shot Anna is by her side Elsa's fear of
hurting others and her inclination to
isolate herself to her own detriment
were major themes of the first film so
it'll be interesting to see if in frozen
- Elsa's tendency to push forward on her
own is still a fatal flaw or if it has
somehow evolved into a strength
at one point in the trailer Paul's Elsa
that if she wants answers she has to
find the source of the voice as he tells
her this he uses his magic to give her a
vision showing three scenes the first is
a brief glimpse at a bridge that looks
like one of the structures of arendelle
the next is two groups of people coming
face-to-face then there's a third image
a staff the swords striking together
this vision could easily foreshadow
events that will occur later in the film
but it could also hint at the past event
Agner referred to Anna story that led to
the Enchanted Forest being sealed off
perhaps the reason it's so important for
Elsa to learn about her past is so she
can prevent similar events from
happening again in the future when Elsa
Anna Kristoff and Olaf take off and
their carriage for their trek north a
tall pillars shaped Mountain can be seen
in the distance if you look closely you
can see Elsa's ice
hasil still there on the side exactly as
it was when she constructed it during
the let it go sequence from frozen since
frozen to is said to take place three
years after the first film it's probably
safe to assume that this means Elsa
still spent some time in her ice castle
although Elsa seems to have made a
healthy home life for herself in
arendelle it would make sense if from
time to time she retreats to her own
northern fortress of solitude to
decompress burn off some magic and
perhaps do a bit of general maintenance
and upkeep once Elsa manages to take her
party through the mist surrounding the
enchanted forest
the arendelle crew encounters a number
of new characters who have been living
on the inside
these include Yelena who leads the north
bull drew people it appears as though
they'll have a significant role to play
in frozen 2 will also meet lieutenant
Mathias who seems to be wearing a
version of an arendelle guards uniform
although it's worth noting that the
design is slightly off from the one we
see in frozen either the Royal Guard
uniform has been updated in the past
three years or a Mathias and his men are
wearing an older version of the uniform
and have been in the forest for a long
time perhaps the character were most
excited about though is the tiny
salamander named Bruni when we see
excitedly lapping up Elsa's magic
snowflakes Bruni was the most adorable
part of the trailer and according to
Olaf voice actor Josh GAD that's just
the beginning
GAD tweeted meets your new future
obsession you have no idea so far in the
frozen verse whenever Rock starts
shaking it's nothing to worry about it's
almost always the kind-hearted
waist-high trolls the same gentle people
who took in Kristoff when he was just a
young boy however frozen to looks to be
introducing a whole new breed of rock
people in the form of towering stone
giants and from the looks of things
they're not very friendly the trailer
sees Anna and Olaf steering a boat
passed a group of sleeping stone giants
keeping quiet so as not to wake them
later we see Anna Kristoff and Sven
fleeing for their lives as a giant
pursues them hurling rocks and then a
number of giants rising up over the
treetops although we're assuming that
the stone giants are
the real villains here there's certainly
a formidable opponent and we're pretty
excited to see what sort of magic Elsa
conjures against them it's a blink and
you'll miss it shot but at one point in
the trailer Kristoff rides spin into the
forest and scoops up Anna
leaving a person who appears to be Elsa
behind on her hands and knees
apparently Kristoff won't hesitate to
save Anna even if it means leaving your
sister behind it's not unexpected
especially if the rumors from d23 are
true and Kristoff plans to propose to
Anna and frozen - but it does feel
significant we know from frozen that
Anna and Elsa will always do everything
they can to save one another but what
happens if Kristoff decides that saving
Elsa is too risky for Anna
we hope that frozen - doesn't come down
to Anna having to choose between her
boyfriend and her sister but if it does
there won't be any contest sorry Chris
sisters before misters in a film that is
presumably all about learning where its
characters came from it's fitting that
we could get a glimpse into the
backstory of one character you've
probably never even wondered about spend
the reindeer we know from frozen that
Sven has been with Kristoff since he was
a little boy but he never really learned
where he was before that well wonder no
longer as it looks like we may finally
get an answer to where spin got his
start in the frozen - trailer we see a
young North full drug girl crossing a
bridge cradling a baby reindeer this
looks a lot like the girl we saw earlier
in the trailer twirling in the air in
the enchanted forest who may very well
be Elsa and Anna's mother Iduna it's
very possible that either Sven or one of
his parents was born in the enchanted
forest and came to arendelle was he
Doudna and her people
meaning that in frozen - he'll be
returning to his natural home this seems
to be supported by shots in both this
and previous trailers have spent running
happily with a herd of reindeer possibly
his original family while we have no
doubt that he and Kristoff will always
remain brothers at heart it could be
nice to see Sven
finally find his place among other
reindeer they are after all better than
people there are several shots in the
new trailer of characters rushing in the
battle both arendelle soldiers and North
Boulder warriors at the beginning of the
trailer they seem to be fighting each
other although it's hard to be sure
while at the end they're charging
towards some unseen foe if they're
fighting one another it could be the
conflict Bobby showed Elsa in her vision
the sword and the staff clashing
together alternately the vision could be
attempting to mislead us and might
actually symbolize the two groups coming
together and fighting as one either way
there's a strong chance that the battle
we keep glimpsing in the trailer isn't
actually one that takes place in the
present timeline it's very possible that
this fight is one that took place long
ago and that's what led to the barring
of the enchanted forest
however even if the conflict is an old
one if it was between arendelle the
north old rough and the mysterious
forces of the forest all of the elements
are there for it to spin up again in
frozen - perhaps this is why the
arendelle born magical Elsa is so
important especially if it turns out
that her mother is North Pole drah she
contains elements of all three and may
be the one who is finally able to bring
about a lasting peace check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]